Voiceover: This video is to
answer some questions part
for the Royal Geographic Society.
This is part of their 21st
Century Challenges Series.
First the general questions, so
the first question right up here is
will changes in education
in the coming decades
be evolutionary or revolutionary?
Evolutionary would kind of imply small
changes, maybe not so noticeable changes
but then maybe over a long period
of time they add up to a lot
or revolutionary, everything all at once.
I hope you don't think that
I'm not answering the question
but I think it's going to be both.
It's already been stated independent
of education that we are in
and information revolution right now
and I think that's pretty obvious.
First you have the computers and
then obviously you have the internet.
Everything now becomes accessible and
it's becoming all of that more accessible
every almost moment that passes by.
The funny thing is the
information revolution
and there's no industry that revolves
around information more than education.
I guess there's other industries that
are close like finance and whatever else.
But education really is about, I
would say information or knowledge
or conveying information
or transferring understanding
from one person to another.
It is really about a
transferring information
or a communication
between different people.
The information revolution
should I guess naturally,
the education revolution
should be part of it,
and it really just maybe
hasn't for a bunch of reasons.
There are different [nurses] in
place to keep it from changing.
My sense is and this
is true of many things,
is that when people are most
pessimistic about something
that's when it's about to change in
a really, really, really big way.
That's when it's about to give
and I think we are at that
moment in education where,
sure people have been talking about
technology education for a long time.
People have been trying to
improve education for a long time
but the unfortunate narrative is every
year we just hear things of get ...
They see more at least based on the
narrative we're hearing in the media.
It seems like it's getting worse,
getting more expensive too.
So depending on how you do it,
either worse performance at
kind of the grade school levels
or at the higher education levels just
getting more and more and more expensive
and less affordable.
Even if you can afford and you take
on the loans it's becoming less clear
that you're able to even get the
return when you go into the job market,
whether you've been
[necessarily] not employable.
So yes, I think the revolution is coming.
I think it's going to come
in a bunch of different ways.
I think you're going to start
seeing a decoupling of learning
from credentialing.
Right now, the word education
is even kind of modeled
because it's actually a
whole bunch of things.
Inside of education you
have the idea of learning
and this is what most people
associate with education.
You also have the idea of
credentialing which is,
"I got a degree from here or there."
Then you also have an
element of socialization
which is a very important
element, socialization.
When people talk about education it's
not clear what they're talking about,
most people are talking about ...
Think they're talking about this
but when you ask them why they're
willing to go $200,000 in debt,
they'll be talking about this right here.
What I hope to see is that
this actually becomes decoupled
and when it becomes decoupled, it
becomes actually more interesting.
Because if someone can earn a
credential by proving what they know
and they don't have to sit
some place for four years
and they don't have to pay $200,000,
then all of a sudden the learning
will happen in whatever way
is easiest for that person.
It could be through something
like the Khan academy,
it could be attending a
traditional university, it
could be learning on the job.
What's powerful that is if the credential
is done independently from that,
then the credential can also
become much more powerful.
Right now you have a reality where
you have thousands of universities,
and I'll talk about universities,
the high school diploma has
become almost meaningless now.
No one even says, "I'll give you a job
because you have a high school diploma."
They don't know what that even means.
On the other side of it you have
people getting into universities
that don't have a high school diploma.
That just have really good
standardized test scores
and they've done amazing things
when they were before college,
and they were home schooled or whatever.
What you have right now is the
credentialing is kind of been done
by the same people who
are doing the learning.
It makes everyone say,
"Well look, how do we know what the
standards are in that university?"
"How do we know what the standards
are at that high school?"
That's what's making standardized
tests and all of that so valuable,
regardless of whether you
actually view them as valuable
but that's why people are
putting so much emphasis on them.
What would be valuable is if the
credentials is more recognized.
If there's a nationally or
internationally recognized credentials
because right know you could
go to a regional university.
Maybe your regional university
or your local community college,
maybe it's amazing at this, maybe
it's better than Harvard at this,
maybe it's better than any
university at the teaching part,
and maybe it's graduates actually
do know the material really, deeply,
and amazing, and they know it
better than the kids graduating
from the Ivy League.
But the sad reality right
now is even if they do,
their credential will not carry as much
weight in the eyes of most employers
as that Harvard degree will or that
Stanford degree, or that MIT degree.
So they have a credentialing problem,
but if you decouple this things
the students will learn from
the regional university,
could go and prove that they know
it just as good as anyone else.
I think you're going to see
some very interesting things
or I think once you open this up
and people can get the credential
and obviously the cost of getting tested,
even if it's a very rigorous test,
even if it's a more rigorous test
than what's going on right now
in the best universities, that's
not going to cost 50,000 a year.
You ask a university right now why
they're charging 50,000 a year,
they'll say, "Look at our
facilities. Look at our campus."
"Look at our professor's salaries."
They don't say, "We're
charging you $50,000 a year"
"because we're giving you
really rigorous exams."
"We're giving you oral
exams and all the rest."
If you ask students why they're
paying $50,000 they'll tell you,
that for the most part they're
paying for the credentials,
and then some students
hopefully for the learning,
and then some for the socialization and
that socialization can take many forms.
I suspect the credentialing
itself can be done in a better way
than it's being done now.
That can be much cheaper, I'm
talking in orders hundreds of dollars
as opposed to thousands of dollars.
Then it opens up the learning
part to whatever works best,
and I suspect once you do that
then now higher education
institutions won't have
this kind of control over the market
and it will be very hard
for them to justify raising
their tuition 6% every year
and it would be very hard for them to ...
They would have to prove the case
that it really is worth $50,000
that their graduates really are
performing better on these credentials
than say people who use the Khan Academy
or go to their local community college
or learn on the job.
I think you're definitely
going to see that coming.
I think in 10 years or so
you're going to see that shift
and you're actually going to see that
tuition cost you're going to give.
Because they're already becoming
so unaffordable for so many people
that I think everyone's going
to wake up at some point
and realize that there
has to be another way.
How important is knowledge
in a modern education?
Knowledge is one of these words that
depends how you think about knowledge.
Is knowledge fact information?
Is it a specific skill set?
Is it a medal level skill of
kind of knowing how to learn
and some would say it's all of the above.
What I would say is what I think
are the most important things
in a modern education, I think
it's the ability to be creative.
I think it's the ability to
kind of go into an open space
where nothing is defined and
be able to look at the tools
that are available to you and put
something together that meets a problem.
Actually this could be in a technical
sense or it could be in a business sense
or a market, whatever sense.
I think the most important thing is that
people should get from their education
is the ability to make things,
the ability to create things.
Unfortunately that's the thing
that I think is completely absent
from our current education.
One example is Math and
there's a huge debate
about what's the best way to
teach Math is and all the rest.
What's shocking is that no one ever says,
"Well maybe there should be engineering
in education to some degree,"
that's limited by people's perception
of whether we can get proper
engineering even taught.
Whether we can find a talented
teacher in the engineering in schools.
But no one ever says, because
frankly the ability to engineer,
and I'm saying engineering in
the broadest sense of the word,
not what people normally
associate with engineering.
I'm saying engineering which is really,
most people don't normally associate
it as a deeply creative field,
but it is a deeply creative.
In fact engineering is, by
it's very nature, it's creating
things that never existed before.
Engineering is not something
that's emphasized right now.
There might be music class and music
class is focused on playing things
but you see very little composition at
especially at the K through 12 level.
Everything is focused on playing
things that someone else has written.
So the creativity is
de-emphasized in school right now.
I think that's the very thing
that has to be emphasized a lot,
a lot more heavily, not just ability.
Because frankly and this is
the reality of the modern world
is that the tools are going to
change, the jobs are going to change,
the information you need to know
for that job are going to change
but what you really need
to do is that ability to
one, create something out of
nothing, so that's the creativity.
I would say the second thing is this
ability to kind of self-teach yourself.
Look at the resources
that are in the world
to give yourself the tools you need
to be able to create that thing.
The next question, if the
era of a job for life is over
and we need to be more adaptable,
do you foresee a future of people
self-educating through their life?
My peripheral vision was
reading this question.
So yes, I think self-educating
throughout life,
beyond just the economic aspects of
it, maybe being a requirement now
because the world is changing so
fast and jobs are changing so fast,
but I also just think it's helpful,
healthy from a happiness point of view.
Just as people go to the
gym, they do exercise
and not because they're going
to compete in some sport.
Not because they're paid
to compete in exercises,
they do it because it's
good for their health
and they do it because they
know it makes them happy.
There's even these studies,
endorphins get released in
your brain and all of that.
I think the exact same
thing is to of learning,
I mean you're just exercising a different
part of what it means to the human.
You're exercising your brain.
One, I think is going to
be an economic imperative.
You will need to self-educate
through your life.
I mean going back to this answer, the
context is going to keep changing,
the only skill that will
really be valuable is the
ability to learn very quickly
and then apply it in a creative way
to create something that
has never existed before.
I also think hopefully people
will start to recognize
that self-education is
an economic imperative
but it's also a really satisfying thing
that will give people more happiness
than many of the things that people
perceive will give them happiness.
Like more square footage or a fancier car.
Now Khan Academy related,
what are your aspirations for
the growth of the khan Academy?
Our attitude towards growth is,
I mean we'd obviously love as many
students as possible to use it,
but our attitude is let's
focus on what we are producing.
Let's make sure it's this
compelling of an experience
for the people who are using
it as right now as possible.
If we do that, other people
will find it compelling as well.
Those people who are using it and
finding it valuable right now,
will tell other people.
In terms of user growth, I mean I
can hope that it continues to grow
at the rate it's doing, it
grew tenfold this past year
and we're about two million
unique students a month.
We don't want to get to 20 million or
200 million and have a bad experience.
Our main focus is keep
tight on the experience.
If you talk about growth
from a future point of view,
we hope to expand the faculty
and this is something I've
started hinting at a little bit.
I don't want to be the
only person teaching.
I do want to teach on Khan
Academy the rest of my life
but I think there's other people
who will bring super
valuable voices to the table.
We're going to expand the faculty
and you'll hear more about
this in the coming months.
We're also going to expand kind
of what the platform that we have.
We hope to enable students to
communicate with each other,
and to turn really into
a community experience
and we just have to think
of a good way to do that.
Obviously expanding the faculty
but this also goes with
the software part of it.
We want to expand the content
base of both the video side
but also the exercises.
Eventually you can also use Khan
Academy as a way to learn art history,
or to learn chemistry, whatever,
to actually practice those things.
Your thoughts on flipping the
classroom, I thought this was fantastic.
Well thank you for
thinking it was fantastic
but one thing I want to emphasize
because I talk about flipping
the classroom in that Ted talk
and got a lot of press,
and the notion is that
these high school teachers were saying,
"Hey, Sal gave a lecture so let's ..."
My students watch Sal's video
and then the teacher can use
class time for interaction,
I 110% agree with that idea.
What we're advocating now
is taking that even further.
It's not even a pure flip,
it's now every student whether
they're at home or at the classroom,
working at their own
pace at their own time
and then the teacher intervenes
either when there's a need to do the
interactive project or a conversation,
or the teacher intervenes when
they see a student being stuck.
You can go to a pure
flip then when you go,
what we're talking about it becomes
a little less pure of a flip.
We're saying, "Look if a
kid needs to watch a video"
"in the classroom, that's okay."
We don't think that the classroom
should be about watching videos
but if that's what they
need at that moment,
or that kid, not all the kids,
that kid they can watch the video.
If they want to do exercise
at home that's great.
But the important thing is
that they can fully leverage
the humans in the classroom,
their peers and the teacher.
Then the teacher spending
every moment of his or her time
in meaningful interaction with students
and really taking them to the next level.
Then the last question is,
your thoughts on the potential
of game mechanics and ICT,
in general to encourage
the learning process.
Any clear evidence in the Khan Academy?
There is this layer of points
and badges, and streaks
and things like that in the Khan Academy.
Anecdotaly it seems like a lot
of kids find it compelling,
even the data in the school
it looks like a lot of kids
became more engaged when
we threw this layer on.
But we're constantly
experimenting with it,
we're constantly making sure that
it's driving the right behaviors,
that the kids aren't just looking
at the badges or the points
but they really are getting good gains
and they're trying to enjoy
the learning process itself.
The evidence, we saw really
good results from Los Altos.
I actually put some of those results
in a previous video that I made today,
so you can look at that.
That's why Los Altos
is going district wide.
Not clear if that's due to the
game mechanics or due the content
or some combination of both of them.
We hope to continue to explore this
and we're talking to teachers and students
constantly about how to tweak this,
so we can make it a better experience.
We also hope to put a lot of
our game mechanics right now
for the most part extrinsic, so they're
independent of the subject at hand.
We also want to put a lot
of intrinsic motivator,
so some of the exercises
themselves are like games
but their games that are where deep
subject matter help you solve the game.
This is something that we're
just going to constantly try
to iterate on it and address.
This brings to an important issue
as we've gotten a lot of press
and we think hopefully that we
are having an impact right now.
But we think we're very
early on in the process,
so we don't think that we
have all the solutions.
I think what is kind of the opportunity
that we have in the Khan Academy,
what excites me is that
we do have the traction
that we can now become the best lab
for really figuring out what works
and then getting traction on that.
We view ourselves where
we're early in the game
and the baseball now is your top
of the first inning right now.
Maybe I should make a cricket analogy
but I don't understand cricket.
We think we're really early on and so
we think it's a very open ended question
on where we're going to take this.
We really just want to be open minded
about building stuff, looking at the data,
looking at the feedback and
then taking that seriously
and then continuing to refine it.